[Música]
es un autor francés con apellido español
El que llevaba su abuela paterna y que
escogió como seudónimo al publicar su
primera novela una educación libertina
en esa época todavía era trabajador
social y quería distinguir su vida
profesional de lo que empezaba a hacer
su vida de escritor pero 12 años y
cuatro libros después John Batista
convertido en un artista multipremiado
invitado en esta edición de la feria del
libro de Bogotá lo conocimos unos meses
antes en el high festival donde presentó
su última obra El hijo del hombre una
inquietante novela sobre el trama y la
violencia en el seno del hogar
Muchas gracias por compartir este
momento con nosotros en Franz 24
usted es el único escritor francés
presente en esta edición del High
festival en Colombia Qué significa este
evento para usted que siente al estar
aquí entre todos estos autores
escritores periodistas y pensadores
internacionales
como lector de literatura
latinoamericana es importante para mí
aceptar estas invitaciones responder
favorablemente a ellas acompañar este
libro siempre es muy mágico para un
autor tener un libro traducido a otro
idioma que se encuentra con otras
culturas otros imaginarios Así que
siempre es una alegría tanto viajar para
conocer a los lectores como por supuesto
a los autores que también podemos
conocer en estas ocasiones
[Música]
el tema de la conferencia en la que ha
participado aquí es la transmisión de la
violencia que está en el corazón de su
quinta novela El hijo del hombre la
historia de un recinto al aire libre un
hombre una mujer y su hijo en una vieja
casa en medio de la montaña Por qué
quiso dedicar un libro entero a la
violencia intergeneracional con este
escenario en particular
problema o al menos una cuestión una
ansiedad fundamental que me acompaña
desde hace muchos años que he intentado
abordar en diferentes libros y siempre
tengo la sensación de que un libro
contiene las semillas del siguiente y
resulta que mi libro anterior que se
llama reino animal ya trataba esta
cuestión de la transmisión de la
violencia pero a lo largo de cinco
generaciones a lo largo de un siglo
Había algo así como una escala casi
histórica como un mural histórico cuando
terminé reino animal tuve la sensación
de que tal vez me había dejado algo en
la sombra y me dije que eligiendo el
contrapunto formal de ese libro teniendo
solo tres personajes y casi solo una
localización tal vez podría por fin
intentar explorar de forma diferente
esta cuestión de la transmisión de la
violencia y efectivamente hoy tengo la
sensación de que con el hijo del hombre
hay algo para mí que ha terminado en
esta investigación y que es una cuestión
que probablemente me acompañará menos en
los próximos libros
años
luego esta historia este escenario y la
forma en que lo cuenta realmente se
siente como que podría ser que hacía una
especie de tragedia griega está la
noción de fatum de este destino que está
sellado que pesa sobre los hombros de
los personajes pero a diferencia de
otras historias les da a su personaje se
está especies de premonición tienen la
sensación de que algo les va a pasar
este mundo de la tragedia le ha
inspiradora si en este deseo que tenía
de intentar Encontrar imágenes casi
arcaicas primitivas fundadoras de la
violencia en el seno de la familia me di
cuenta rápidamente mientras trabajaba en
el texto que sería interesante darle una
dimensión casi mitológica en tanto en
cuanto que mis personajes como es
comprensible proceden de una clase
trabajadora muy Modesta y no quería
confinarlos a una forma de realismo
social al contrario quería intentar
dibujarlos en otra parte hacer de ellos
figuras casi trágicas me pareció que el
libro puede leerse al mismo tiempo como
una forma de Thriller casi
con vistas Así es progresivamente hay
cosas que se van revelando
absolutamente con una forma de suspense
que espero que mantengan lector ocupado
pero también puede percibirse de otra
manera como un texto simbolista que
tiene un significado más amplio más
universal
si es una significación
las imágenes que más me conmovieron
fueron cuando el niño llega a la casa
donde creció el padre y Es verdad que
muchas veces nos imaginamos Cómo era
nuestro padre o nuestra madre a nuestra
edad es que así como una peregrinación y
era su habitación pasar tiempo en esos
lugares donde vivieron y es normal
porque son nuestros primeros modelos es
esta admiración pura poderosa y ciega
que podemos tener por nuestros padres
cuando Somos niños lo que nos lleva
inevitablemente a decepcionarnos un día
porque nuestros padres son humanos
tienen su lado Y en este caso pueden ser
un peligro
[Música]
más aún en este caso ya que el padre
regresa tras años de ausencia y el hijo
apenas le ha conocido Así que ha
fantaseado con la imagen de lo que es un
padre y cuando este hombre reaparecen
sus vidas y se ofrece a llevarles a esa
casa perdida en las montañas donde él
mismo creció con un padre complicado una
figura así bastante oscura y preocupante
es una oportunidad para que el hijo
descubra Quién es ese padre e intente
acercarse a él y efectivamente poco a
poco se dará cuenta de que las
intenciones de este hombre son mucho más
turbias de lo que parecía y que en
realidad representará una amenaza para
él y para la madre
y si el padre parece Reproducir lo que
su propio padre le transmitió por otro
lado usted nos cuenta que la madre está
en oposición a su propia madre y ella
rompe por ejemplo con la prohibición de
mostrar el cuerpo y la desnudez en la
que ella creció para estar a gusto con
su propio hijo Por qué triunfa la madre
donde fracasa el padre
no sé si triunfa porque desgraciadamente
será víctima de la violencia de este
hombre Pero por otro lado es una mujer
que aspira una forma de libertad y por
eso desgraciadamente va a darle una
segunda oportunidad a este hombre con la
esperanza de que tal vez le ofrezca otro
modelo de vida creció en una pequeña
ciudad de provincia lucha contra los
determinismos sociales familiares y
económicos y soñaba con otra vida soñaba
con el amor soñaba con una forma de
libertad y no cabe duda de que esa
libertad La conquistó en parte
construyéndose en oposición a su madre
sobre todo en su relación con la
sensualidad con el cuerpo y luego la
madre es También en esta novela una
forma de refugio para el hijo al final
es un libro bastante oscuro pero los
momentos de luz de poesía de
apaciguamiento son esos momentos en los
que el hijo se encontrará en compañía de
la madre y podrán compartir juntos una
gran ternura
parece como si encontráramos en el hijo
Esta dualidad entre los femenino y lo
masculino y estaba leyendo algunas
entrevistas en las que usted habla del
peso del patriarcado esta idea de la
transmisión de la violencia entre
generaciones es algo más fuerte y
complicado para los hombres
si estoy absolutamente convencido de que
hay una forma de violencia sistémica que
es específica del patriarcado de la
transmisión de una forma de
representación de lo que es la
masculinidad y que los hijos a menudo
luchan contra esto así que me atrevo a
esperar que sean capaces de liberarse de
ella que es también la cuestión de la
novela si este hijo logrará o no escapar
a esta transmisión de la violencia pero
en es una cuestión que me ha preocupado
creo casi desde mis primeras novelas
[Música]
este padre en la novela tiene algo de
animal cuando hablas de sus dientes
hablas de caninos de que robe carne con
sus propias manos de hecho en un momento
dado la madre habla de él como de un
animal cuyos próximos movimientos no
puede predecir es esta imagen que tenía
en mente cuando escribía
[Música]
creo que ya de por sí las figuras
paternas de mis novelas han sido a
menudo figuras bastante amenazadoras Y
es algo que he ido declinando de texto
en texto porque a menudo volvemos sobre
los mismos motivos tratando de agotarlos
y este padre rápidamente entendí que
debía representar una amenaza muy física
siendo que es un libro en el que recurro
muy poco a la psicología Así que intento
prestar mucha atención a los gestos a
los cuerpos a la forma en que los
personajes se sitúan situación realmente
quería que la mera presencia del físico
de este hombre creará una forma de
inquietud una amenaza permanente algo
que se siente en cuanto está en compañía
de la madre y el hijo y efectivamente
como es un hombre que quiere poseerlo
todo que también lucha porque no solo es
un bastardo también es en parte víctima
de su propia historia lucha con lo que
su padre le dejó pero tiene este deseo
de control este deseo de Posesión y
finalmente el entendimiento natural
entre la madre y el hijo se vuelve
rápidamente insoportable para él ya que
le gustaría conseguir arrastrar al hijo
hacía así
y hablan de imágenes su libro tiene un
lado muy cinematográfico se detiene
mucho en las texturas los efectos de la
luz sobre los árboles sobre la
naturaleza ya dije y ya dirigió un
primer cortometraje en 2018 el cine y el
trabajo audiovisual en general le llama
el cine siempre me ha nutrido y me sigue
nutriendo es cierto que intento trabajar
con un enfoque muy visual Por otra parte
el cine también es un campo
especialmente complicado y al acercarme
a esta práctica artística comprendí la
libertad que tenía como novelista cuando
escribo una novela estoy solo a bordo lo
decido todo en el cine es diferente
porque tienes 10 20 30 personas que
opinarán sobre lo que haces así que me
debato entre el deseo de renovar la
experiencia de intentar profundizar un
poco más en esta investigación Y luego
el hecho de permanecer en mi burbuja
mucho más preservada y mucho más natural
también Creo yo que es la de la
literatura
Muchas gracias gracias a usted